voilà il pourrait évoquer la situation
notamment à odessa notre chroniqueur
international bruno daroux nous a
rejoint bonjour brno bonjour antoine
bruno on a dit non codées sa nouvelle
cible sur mandat de l'armée russe au
delà de au delà de ça bruno le demain de
nouvelles nouvelles rentes de
négociations doivent avoir lieu est ce
que dans ce contexte on peut peut-être
assister une sorte de nouvelle phase
dans cette guerre selon alors en fait on
est déjà entré dans une nouvelle phase
de la guerre c'est à dire qu'en gros ce
sont désormais les grandes villes du
pays qui sont pris pour cible par
l'armée russe il ya bien sûr pierre
bayard en parler kharkiv marioupol et
puis au dessin qui est un peu là la
prochaine sur la liste qui j'ose dire
parce que pour le moment selon les
ukrainiens vous l'avez entendu sont des
tirs de roquettes et des tirs de
missiles il n'y a pas encore de
bombardements à odessa mais ça ne
saurait tarder malheureusement encore
une fois selon les ukrainiens donc on
est entré dans cette phase où les russes
doivent rentrer dans le dur si vous
voulez c'est à dire sans parler des
grandes villes du pays sans faire trop
de dégâts si possible mais en s'assurant
quand même face à une résistance
ukrainienne qui est beaucoup plus forte
que ce qu'ils espéraient bain sans
essayer de faire trop de trop de dégâts
ça va être compliqué et puis il y as
pendant ce temps effectivement ces
pourparlers russes et ukrainiens qui se
poursuivent le troisième round c'est
pour demain alors est-ce qu'on va rester
dans la gestion finalement du conflit ce
qui est important en s'assurant que des
corridors humanitaires puissent
effectivement être mise en place et
n'ont pas annoncé puis finalement on y
renonce pas ce que le part et d'autre
les violations du cessez-le-feu sont
trop nombreuses comme ce qui s'est
produit à marioupol donc ça c'est
important mais vous voyez qu'on est dans
la gestion du conflit on ne débouche pas
encore sur un un compromis huit
concessions pour le moment là il n'y a
pas de compromis politiques ou
diplomatiques
entre les 2 parties tout simplement
parce que leurs positions sont beaucoup
trop éloignée merci beaucoup bonheur